olá a boa tarde colegas han em começar
essa minha apresentação com um pequeno
spoiler que provavelmente vai frustrar
alguns de vocês aqui é sobre o fim da
minha palestra que ela não terá fim na
provavelmente terá reticências
a pesquisa está no início e vou tentar
propor pra vocês aqui uma forma de
refletir sobre a minha pesquisa
mas antes disso acho que é interessante
colocar dois breves momentos que marcam
a a a minha entrada na ciência e como eu
eu comecei a refletir sobre isso e como
coloca uma pesquisadora e mídia viotti
da costa existem momentos que certas
circunstâncias elas se acumulam e te
fazem pensar sobre determinados momentos
históricos pensando sobre um desses
momentos com certeza foi quando eu
estava na escola
acho que é importante contar essa breve
história fazendo a 5º ano da do ensino
fundamental e até uma prova sobre gregos
romanos ea professora marina era o nome
dela
ao apresentar a questão falou por favor
o que gostaria que vocês escrevessem
baseado no que eu ensinei vocês a partir
da história dos povos gregos e romanos
uma história sobre um povo fictício eu
comecei a naquele momento a chorar pois
não entende a questão até que ela veio
me perguntar qual é a questão
a professora eu estudei tudo responde
para ela tudo sobre os gregos tudo sobre
os romanos mas não estudei nada sobre os
povos fictícios
nesse momento eu vi que esse meu
interesse pela história era importante
pulando temporalmente alguns anos mais
tarde estou eu
na já trabalhando no instituto do
patrimônio histórico nas missões e um
dia durante mais um desses projetos de
arqueologia que são executados em
qualquer lugar do mundo seja no egito na
grécia
estamos executando um trabalho ali na
fonte missioneira uma fonte de água do
século 17 e 18
nesse momento era um domingo vota a
igreja
já a população inteira da cidade reunida
a em prece por que era o momento de uma
grande estiagem
naquela cidade naquele município e
dependiam absurdamente da chuva chuva é
algo extremamente importante para aquela
comunidade a partir de então eu vi
aquela pesquisa que estava fazendo e não
estava relacionada com a comunidade era
necessário pensar de que forma um
cientista deve inserir dentro de um
projeto de pesquisa que é executado numa
comunidade pois então passamos as
missões o que seriam as opções
as missões sucintamente durante séculos
17 e 18 o brasil não era o brasil era um
território em disputa não estavam
definidas claramente as fronteiras
espanha/portugal disputavam essas
fronteiras a e durante o tratado de
madri 1850 é determinada um novo limite
territorial existiam 30 povos que eram
ocupados em torno cada uma como se
fossem pequenas cidades
dois padres jesuítas em cerca de 7.000 8
mil indígenas em cada um desses povoados
neste local foi feita uma definição
clara de fronteira e uma parte da
disputa o vaduz que eram com dizer assim
de posse da espanha passariam ao
controle português
desses sete estavam no atual território
brasileiro essa não foi uma saída fácil
pois eles não se recusaram a sair
os jesuítas era uma época de expulsão
também dos jesuítas da américa os ame
enviavam os índios guaranis combateram
foram as guerras guarani éticas e
duraram dez anos até que foram expulsos
e o o o território é ocupado
ela é localizada aqui nessa região
principalmente nos séculos 17 18 essas
ocupações por aqui tá e elas a partir do
século 19 são abandonadas claro que não
completamente abandonadas
elas são abandonadas temporariamente mas
ainda era um local de visitação
principalmente pelo caráter religioso
que elas dispunham
elas tinham caráter religioso
o ativo simbólico muito importante e
durante o século 20 e início do século
20 e começam obras de restauração em
consolidação dessas estruturas
a partir da década de 30 principalmente
com a fundação do instituto do
patrimônio histórico e getúlio vargas
ele ali daquela região é uma época diz a
desautorização no caráter nacional e da
valorização também do regionalismo
começam obras naquela região oeste do
rio grande do sul
essas obras permitirão que hoje em dia
essas ruínas estejam consolidadas
principalmente essa aqui ela tem uma
característica que está plenamente
consolidada assumindo uma característica
de um arquitetônica do século 19 do
violet duque com muitas obras de
restauro e consolidação já essa outra
que fica ali próximo é no sítio
arqueológico de são lourenço uma outra
missão ela já tem um caráter muito mais
bucólico romântico de ruína é uma outra
característica até essas ovelhas foram
feitos testes de rastreamento genético
dela e conseguiu estabelecer que elas
são da época das missões do século 17 e
18 às pessoas até brinca com elas não
seriam ovelhas elas seriam o velhinhas a
partir da década de 70 final de 70 e 80
começam grandes obras de escavação
arqueológica na região
essas grandes obras de escavação
arqueológica tendã a ampliar e conhecer
todo o território mas ao mesmo tempo foi
deixado de lado a atividade de
consolidação não adianta só vocês cavar
você tem que preservar você tem que
consolidar e proteger o que você está
revelando através das escavações
arqueológicas senão isso se perde chuva
sol frio calor animais passando em cima
nesse sentido as escavações começaram a
ampliar foram aberto foi possível
conhecer um grande espaço o da região de
como era uma antiga redução ea partir de
então essas escavações deixam de ser
apenas a
para o interesse arquitetônico década de
a valorização dos direitos humanos
outros interesses começam a ser
valorizados é necessário conhecer não só
a estrutura arquitetônica é necessário
conhecer quem ele viveu e ali viveu uma
história que não pode ser baseada apenas
no conhecimento de uma igreja por
exemplo que era o núcleo central ali
daquela a redução mas é necessário
conhecer também o passado indígena
daquela região valorizar outros
personagens históricos
essas escavações começam então a ter
outros interesses também por exemplo a
entrada da igreja a outros locais que
seriam importantes
a fonte de água missioneira aquela que
mencionei na minha história que era
necessário é importante conhecer de que
forma ela foi importante para a vida
daquela comunidade no século 18 19
era necessário também trabalhar com
crianças é necessário também essa
atividade o que ficou conhecido na área
de tecnologia que é a educação
patrimonial é necessário divulgar é
necessário saber trabalhar com esse
conhecimento e à extroversão atividades
foram sendo feitas para evitar problemas
como por exemplo caçadores de tesouro
que freqüentemente atacam o local em
busca desmontando materiais desmontando
peças é necessário proteger o bem
arqueológico que está guardado em
estruturas em museus é necessário
desenvolver projetos que conjuguem e
consigam trazer as crianças para a
próxima ao sítio elas são um aspecto
importante para a construção desse
conhecimento e sobretudo é necessário
como diz um livro de um fã ta1 estourado
um escritor americano da geração perdida
décadas de 30 e 40
perguntaram o pó é um dos livros dele é
necessário você como arqueólogo também
olhar para esse passado e saber que
milhares de pessoas centenas de pessoas
por ali passaram olhar para o presente e
olhar para o futuro também mas não
esquecer também as dezenas e centenas de
pessoas que passam e esses devem ser
valorizados a partir daí eu deixo os
três pontinhos
como fazer isso como olhar para esse
passado sem perder de vista e futuro é
um tema que é trabalhado no meu projeto
de pesquisa eu gostaria então de
agradecer ao convite para poder
participar desse evento do tedx gostaria
também de agradecer ao laboratório de
ecologia pública do nepam e também
agradecer a todos que estão aqui
presentes e também assistindo essa
palestra muito obrigado